share with me a little bit more about
what you're what the event is and and
how
sure give some guidance so it's caps
which is
canada's nsa it's our national
convention
which is all virtual and i've been asked
to co-emcee the event
so there are 25 appearances
through the three days kind of thing um
some are only a minute and it's just a
clear
throw to the next thing which is fine
but there are some 10 minute
6 minute five minute three minute um
segments
and i have a co-host old white guy
french canadian
so we're gonna play a little bit with
diversity i'm like your bipark
i i i know he so we've got some things
to riff
on that are you know in your face um
but we were thinking of our idea for it
to kind of have a thread
through the three days whenever we pop
up was to do a kind of letterman top ten
but count down over the three days good
that's kind of what what this is this is
just my ideas right
but and what i wanted to do is like the
ten tough things about covet or about
but flip them so so because
we could go into a whole dark thing and
i want to have some poignancy
um some we're gonna have a couple of
stories each about like real stuff
but i want the top 10 to be a little
lightness punctuating through the event
right because because otherwise i think
i'd be like oh it's claire and bernard
who goes by bear so it's claire bear
that's showing up all the time
okay and so we have to
banter between us now i'm not gonna be
in the studio so i'm gonna be
here at my desk he's going to be in the
studio
and we have to dance together yeah
as co-host so it's the it's kind of just
wanting to check in with you
and see hey do you have any suggestions
based on that's the context of what
we're doing
be the top 10 i could bounce a couple of
things off you and just like
because i'm not a joke teller i'm
usually only in this
firing back and forth in conversation
and i love it when i get people laughing
and and i will self-deprecate and and do
all kinds of things
in that moment i don't know what's going
to come up in the emcee environment
but that's that's kind of what i'm what
i was hoping to talk to you about
yeah so a couple of questions to kind of
help frame that is
first of all is it a live experience is
it
pre-recorded is it a mix of both will
you be live with some pre-recorded or
exactly
live things okay i'll be we'll bear and
i will be totally live
some of the keynotes are live and some
of them like brian tracy and joe sharon
are coming up there where theirs is
recorded
so i i may have access to some of it
beforehand
so i could prepare but a lot of it will
be
it'll be a tiring time to be listening
for six hours
and riffing off everything and to be
perfectly honest it's a lot of work to
do
some of them reworking sometimes it's
like almost better that that in the
moment thing
uh and for the how is the experience
um how are people experiencing it are
you in
zoom is it going to be streamed out
through like vimeo stream
to another event platform it's going to
be through
from zoom to an event platform or
actually no we're going to be we're
going to be in another
event platform as individuals and as
presenters broadcasting
in there so there's going to be a whole
production team
um uh on air okay on air i've heard of
it i don't think that i've seen it so i
think a couple of things do you know
is there a how much of a delay is there
between
what um you say and when the audience
hears it
don't know good question okay yeah okay
so
uh yeah just a couple of just a little
bit of background context
zoom is great if you're bringing people
in because it is relatively
instant it's maybe a half second delay
or something like that in terms of so
there is a slight adjustment for
this gets comedians all the time of like
the first time they're doing a virtual
show
they don't realize it takes time for
your joke to go to
the other person and then for them to
laugh and it to come back and so what
people do and humor a lot of times is
what they call step
on laughter where you say something
funny
yeah but you know the audience has to
process it and with virtual it takes
even longer for it to get to them
and then the audience is getting ready
to laugh but then you start talking
again
yes and uh they stop laughing because
they want to hear what you say next
um so with virtual makes a little bit
harder with this live the
challenge with it if there is any type
of delay longer than that even if it's
you know 10 seconds 20 seconds sometimes
it's up to about 30 seconds of a delay
depending on how they are streaming
the impact of that is a couple things
one you have to add a little bit of
those pauses
just being comfortable and confident in
the material that i'm going to add a
pause
and you don't want to be like winking at
the audience when you like
you know i just said that was a joke
yeah
but you just want to like allow it to
land and so the
advice that i give to anyone in a
virtual context
is just assume that you are crushing it
okay
i assume that every joke that you have
planned is like
a fantastic joke that the audience is
going to eat up because
to assume anything else doesn't help
your performance 100
all of a sudden you're you're dancing in
insecurity which is not sexy
to anybody question for you just on this
because bear
is a french speaker and he was going
to like sometimes say
comment in well comment in english on
the joke and i'm like you just killed
the joke
because you over like does is there
something to over explaining a joke that
kills like sucks the life out of it well
it depends on the performance
yes and no it depends on how it's done
like i mean this is
this is sometimes the um
you know the the negative thing of how
people think of like jimmy fallon in
some ways
because jimmy fallon in his show will
say something that he thinks is very
funny and then he will laugh at the joke
a lot and some people love that because
it's like him laughing and so then it's
like we're gonna laugh with him
other people i like it because that's
what i do i'm like i'm funny
my dating profile it said that i think
i'm funny after two glasses of wine like
like
like you have to laugh with me it's an
important it's important attributes
some people like that some people don't
okay um so it depends on also and then
the same thing of over explaining a joke
i think
that if it's a tongue-in-cheek over
explanation
if it's like that's gonna be bear's
personality of like
it's it's like people might not get that
and you can have that inner play back
and forth with them where it's like no
no i think they get it it's like no we
need to make sure that they understand
that this was a joke and then go into
the explanation
yeah that i think could help if it's if
it's like uh no i actually need to
explain this joke then it's like well
it's probably not a well-written joke if
you feel like you're gonna have to
explain why it's funny afterwards unless
that is part of the bit
and i think if he mixes the french in it
could be a great part of the bit because
then it's also helping our french
listeners
yeah right and so i said if you do it in
french i think
that that works beautifully yeah so then
the other thing to
so knowing that it's going out to the
platform um
the other thing to test for sure is
the delay that there's going to be
between you and bear
because some platform there's no delay
and then other platforms there is so for
example cassandra and i when we were
when we were doing the hosting of the
nsa virtual
event we hosted the talent show and
there was
a little bit of a just like not super
long but maybe like a second and a half
delay
and that you just need to know going in
so that it's not like
so claire what was it that was you know
oh you know so claire's going to
share with us you know the top 10 the
number 10 reason
why covet has been tough and then if you
don't know that there's a delay and
don't hear you speak
then well no i'm going to say this and
then you start talking over each other
i don't need to understand what the
package it's like the news anchors that
are throwing remote
and the person's waiting and then they
nod and they go you know like they
like i hear you and they they go so
there's something about throwing to each
other
i think yeah you'll want to have yeah
you'll want to have that
understanding of how long it's going to
be and i think that's where
you know it's going to feel awkward for
you as a host but if you can do it
confidently
right as long as not too long that's
where you're going to be like yep
and then you're just looking at the
camera like take it away um
or you know give it like some facial
expressions can kind of help that
selling of it
um well when i'm nervous i tend to smile
so that usually is worked in my favor
i think that's a great way way better
than like shutting
down if your hammers are pacing
currently just smiling it's like like
so okay so this is this is so helpful so
i'll ask those two questions the
production team and i guess we'll get to
feel it out
and then yeah and then and to test it so
the other thing is
um from a bigger perspective
at least my experience with hosting
virtual events
um some of the benefits of what a
virtual mc can provide is certainly
logistics so i would say for you and
bear to
really understand the technology yeah so
that you can be reminding people of how
to do it so for example if it's like a
remo technology where people can network
a little bit later it's like hey as a
reminder when you go into this break
you're going to be able to network and
the way that you do that is you double
click on a chair and that sends you into
this conversation or
you know if you need to change your
settings for whatever reason it's that
little hamburger menu up icon
like and if you can figure out the the
way to point as well
uh-huh yeah small things are helpful
like hey your chat your
your announcements are going to be over
here to the right you click on that
little green arrow that expands them so
you see it so like learning the
technology i think is very valuable
because you'll be
you can read you can remind people of
that throughout
the event yes um hey just as a quick
reminder if you're just joining us this
is the technology that we're using and
here's how you're going to engage in the
chat
yeah great point great point and
something we hadn't thought about
so yeah it's okay
that's good so yeah understanding the
technology certainly understanding
the um the flow of uh the day who's
coming up getting people's names and
pronunciations correctly
the nice thing with um with virtual is
that it's a little bit easier
at least for me because um so when i do
mc stuff i typically have a teleprompter
um where i then can put my script or my
my introductions and stuff between that
so i'm looking directly at the camera
if i don't have a teleprompter set up
then i encourage having like a computer
right underneath their webcam um with
the text there so that you can be
checking into it and when you need to
get the correct you know pronunciation
of the person's name coming up that
you know you're able to check in on that
so you like so it doesn't have to become
a memorization thing
great because yeah that's not i'm not an
actress so
um that's yeah that's not my forte so
yeah that's great
i will have it yeah i'll have my my run
of show
under the screen that's what i've spent
the time on down we've just had two
meetings on it
and this came up last week so it's been
it's been like okay
um so i spent time on the run of show so
i understand the flow and figured out
what buckets i have to fill
exactly yeah and then having that and
then in between the breaks when you know
you
are setting up okay now we're welcoming
to your screen and some
some of it's a language change right
instead of welcoming to stage welcoming
to the screen
um the uh
when you can like so then someone is
speaking for 30 minutes or 20 minutes or
whatever that's when you can kind of
rearrange and get ready for the next
thing that you're going to
introduce yeah and then along those
lines
of changes of language welcome to your
screen
um we encourage engagement so hopefully
do you know if there's a chat
functionality for the tool
is that there is can people engage that
way there is yeah
i'm a huge fan of the chat it's one of
the right because you're probably not
going to be seeing
audience members my guess is we're no we
won't you're exactly right we don't see
anybody we see
their photo yeah so that that makes it a
little bit tougher but what you as
mc and host can do and i encourage this
kind of you'll give reminders of this
route particularly at the beginning but
you can even set the stage for people
it's like listen you know we know this
is a virtual experience
so often we love to you know as speakers
we love to be on stage
seeing your smiling faces seeing you
nuts hearing your laughter etc
in a virtual environment we don't have
that but what we do have is the chat so
we strongly encourage you to take
advantage of the chat when we're
bringing people to the stage
in lieu of uh you know applause you
don't need to applauds quietly at home
uh you're gonna scare your dog uh but
instead you just put some exclamation
points in the chat
right so we're gonna use exclamation
points as our chat so for example
you know bear's a pretty great guy like
you know let's just give him a
uh a quote-unquote you know virtual
applause by some exclamation points in
the chat oh bear do you feel that like
it feels good doesn't right you can have
a little bit of banter yeah
okay weird there's some right i'm just
seeing exclamation points in the chat
but it does actually feel pretty good so
you know hey anytime throughout that you
want to applaud exclamation point
also things like lol and haha if someone
makes you laugh
yeah you share that in that because it
gives us that feedback
and in particular if something stands
out to you if someone says something
that
is you know an aha moment for you or is
a line that you want to remember
whatever
share that in the chat as well so that
people can see
um you can also take note of that you've
got to think out loud
here exactly yeah well and that's an
advantage
to virtual right yeah that you can think
out loud and you're not
interrupting the speaker at all and so
you want to encourage that engagement
kind of throughout
um as mc and stuff you while someone
else is speaking if you want it to you
could post questions or you could add
some of that as well but that creates a
it creates a community feel right so
then mc if if someone says something
interesting you'd be like oh if uh you
know have other people
experience the same thing that brian
just mentioned right it creates this
kind of like community and environment
and
is trying to take advantage of the fact
that
you know things are are virtual and i
think that's a big part of the role of
being a virtual mc
yeah you're encouraging engagement
you're creating this kind of community
feel
you're explaining the logistics as they
come up and reminding people of it
um certainly you're yeah you're giving
the flow of the agenda reminding of
people of those things
and then the you know one of the big
things is to potentially be ready
for things to go wrong uh from a
technology perspective
and so within uh within comedy
what we call this is is reading the room
or calling the moment
and what people don't often realize is
that uh
you can free plan some of that stuff oh
in the sense that pre-plan not that
you're going to like pretend that
technology isn't working
but you can think of what are kind of
the top things that are most likely to
go wrong
and if that were to happen let me go
ahead and think about now what i might
say
so that you're not flabbergasted in the
moment like honest thing is happening
and what what did i say it's like
oh no we know that if someone's wi-fi or
internet drops while they're supposed to
be presenting
i know when i'm going to come back i'm
going to say blank right
oh my gosh the internet gremlins are out
there right now uh we're gonna work on
getting so and so back into the room but
in the meantime
right and the thing that i like is go
straight to like what are people
learning so far
100 exactly yeah i was thinking your
salvation is the chat if the chat goes
down
oh um hopefully that's never happening
but
but um yeah then the salvation is is is
you know what did we learn from this
give me your top moment and
yeah yeah that'll be and facilitating
that experience yeah we were i was doing
an event and
and one of the speakers was coming in
from wyoming it was like their internet
ended up dropping
and i had to vamp for basically 10
minutes of content as they did some
testing on that side
yeah uh and that was the bit one of the
like the audience was like this is
or the the producer was like this is why
it's so valuable to one have an mc and
two have someone comfortable with
kind of improvisation or adapting to the
moment because
for the audience we just turned it into
a facilitated kind of
um debrief experience where we're able
to say what have you learned so far
today what are you like thinking about
et cetera and you can you can bring this
is also an advantage where the mc is
also
a speaker because you can bring in some
content as well that's related to what
they're talking about
exactly but it can be a little bit of
like you know and what he was talking
about actually reminds me a little bit
of growth mindset so growth mindset is a
little bit this
how many people have experienced that or
a fixed mindset or whatever right so
that helps the other thing
um just very quickly is knowing from
just a pure kind of tactical standpoint
is knowing how long that delay is for
interaction
because if it is 20 to 30 seconds
um then when you are asking something of
the audience this is where it can be
helpful to have
you know the the interplay back and
forth you may want to have intentional
questions throughout so for example even
at the very beginning you might do a
thing of like
hey where are you all joining from go
ahead and share in the chat so we can
kind of get a sense of where people are
are watching today um with a 30 second
delay
it's gonna take 30 seconds for them to
hear that question before they start
typing things in the chat
and so you need to be able to vamp or
fill that time and so the way that i
typically do it is you ask the question
yeah then you give the answer for
yourself
or you know your co-host can kind of
answer that question you can have a
little bit of fun banter back and forth
you ask the question one more time but
that's when it starts to come back in
again but so it would be this kind of
thing
hey yeah where are you watching from you
know for example i'm coming from panama
city in fact my wife and i just moved
from new york city to panama city
uh when we were in new york you know we
lived in a 400 square foot apartment and
started you know got to the point we're
starting to go stir crazy
uh we got started building pillow forts
just so we'd have a new room to explore
uh right so we're finding out where
people are joining from
uh like i said panama city oh we're
starting to see in the chat there's
right so you've just vamped with either
a little bit of story
or you can do it where you're joining
from bear where is it actually that
you're coming from because we're clearly
in different places
and then the other thing that um as an
mc what you can do
is especially for pre-recorded video
you can still create it as making it a
live experience as to
like how you are facilitating that
experience because like hey we've got
you coming in it's up to you and the
organizer to decide
do you want to let people know
pre-recorded or not
um or if you want to kind of think that
it's pseudo live where it's just like
and now we're gonna hear from brian or
do you make it say
and now brian's gonna come to us in a a
video that uh you know recorded a little
bit earlier but while you're watching
we're going to be engaging in the chat
or still
sharing like yeah that and then also
after they come
out of it the live experience becomes
live again because you're like hey we
just watched brian
what are some things you know some
takeaways that you have
um from what he said and oh so and so
and when
giving when we're reacting to the chat
if the people's names are there
use their first name to say oh what a
great point david has about blank
and oh yeah you know samantha is saying
this which i think makes a lot of sense
and
um margaret has this great question
which i like though that using of the
name it it gets people listening and
then also the fact that you've said
other people's names people are like now
they might say my name and like
100 yeah i think the top 10 thing is fun
i think another
it potentially a little bit more content
to create so you may not want to do it
when you first said it my
my initial thought was like oh you could
have different
top ten lists throughout the event so
rather than one list throughout you
could do okay
top ten things that annoy us about ver
like zoom
yeah and it's like just a quicker it's a
it's a quicker list of it of like
you know being on mute and weird
backgrounds and people who don't come
out
who don't show their video and like it's
the top 10 things or then it might be
you know the the top 10 new hobbies that
i've picked up because of
covet bread making and um this or
whatever
the top 10 things that we've all binged
since this has started oh
the top ten in real or maybe it's even
five i've got the top five in real life
breedings for you
right yeah exactly yeah type five all
yeah and maybe it's top five for each of
these things but it's top five
alternatives to handshakes now that
those are no longer a thing like
that can be a running theme throughout
the um conference and i'm a big fan of
that you create a frame for where
you you can use humor and then you just
come back and reuse that same frame but
with slightly different content
and it creates a little bit of a through
line for it you can have the fun back
and forth
because then at the very end you can
even have the top five lists
top that you can have the top five um
list of the top five things that you
chose not to right so we chose not to do
a top five of you know the foods that
we've eaten to make us fat and we chose
not to do a top five
like you can have kind of that almost
self referential call back type camera
that will
yes close things out oh i love that did
you ever do you ever
um cue in visuals like there's gonna be
a production team doing this so if i if
in the top ten i have an image that i
want to throw
is that getting too fancy do you think
or would that be i mean
if it's possible i think it's great i
mean yeah i use a lot of visuals and
what we do
we do a lot of picture-in-picture slides
either be via prezi video
or through the atm mini but yeah i i'm a
big fan of visuals because
one it can be a great punch line for
things it's just
i mean people are on these screens
people are used to watching
netflix and youtube and all this other
stuff with high production values high
entertainment
all of that and so in order to maintain
people's attention
in what you're doing those visuals can
be very helpful
as an mc it becomes a little bit less
important because usually your segments
aren't as
long but if yeah you're going to do a
top five list even if you had a
graphic that's what i'm thinking like
top five right exactly
yeah something that helps helps visually
punch the frame
that the humor frame yeah okay okay
amazing amazing thank you drew thank you
so much absolutely well i hope that it's
a blast like i said feel free to shoot
some stuff over if you want uh some
punch-ups to it but uh
and certainly let me know how it goes i
think it's it's a fun exciting thing to
be able to do